what's half for the hit good morning
today it's the day the game is up right
now I'm gonna check out how it's doing
this is so exciting
it's literally the only thing you boys
are tweeting about it's number one in
Sweden this is so awesome
that's not a bad review I love the music
in the retro style the voice acting is a
big plus best app you can find amazing
game love this style yes thank you for
us it seems like you really love the
game
I'm so happy sleeping I don't want to go
on but ports we have to go it's 3 p.m. I
can't believe how lazy we are today like
we I think we've been doing a lot of
stuff for the vlogs and then now it's
finally like caught up with us and we're
just like we're so tired we don't want
to do anything I mean I want to do stuff
this is I don't I'm really tight I'm
really tired but the game is going so
well that is not the game first of all I
do not expect it to be so awesome
second of all it's number one in u.s.
that's crazy and then I see like a lot
of you bros are like tweeting oh it's
number one in Germany it's number one in
Sweden it's number one in Norway it's
really cool to see how Bros worldwide
are just excited about the game the
Apple Store just started featuring the
game so cool it's a big products a huge
thing and it's nerve-racking
so enjoy the game play the game have fun
with the game now we're gonna go
oh thank you thought I was gonna hit you
you're fine don't worry
Clemmy okay we're going to where we're
going there's the super popular place we
don't know why but it's always packed
whenever we drive past it so it's 3 p.m.
so we figured that we know people if you
can hear me that's great alright see you
there okay I'm buying these I lost shop
like these because I'm such a little kid
I like this one it's a wallet we're
going there
it looks very full but not as full as
usually so we'll be okay
it was good but come on how many people
for that no pain bruh who's uh who's
that girl standing there it's so weird
to be on bench yes I think know where I
am
that's right in Minecraft you [ __ ]
Museum yes that's me right before we
left the uber drivers like five stars
did you hear that
okay Marsha I really wanted to see these
they're cool walking through why should
I go
I don't know
look it's Jennifer everything is closed
apparently we're so lazy today oh my god
I want to go underneath the rock that's
cool
let's go oh man to skateboard down here
I want to do that really bad look at
that beast okay let's go underneath
please don't pull okay I think we're
fine I've heard about this it's supposed
to be Tar Pits it's like this really
black disgusting thing I don't how to
explain tar how do you explain tar
yeah it's kind of unaccounted coal at
the same time it looks pretty sad yeah
there's more pits let's go check out the
other pits
Gaming muscles always comes first
thank you this one is mine the most
exciting tar pit Wow
in that tar pit so many tar pits
I can't keep up what's yeah what if she
she run away
what's yeah what are you doing come here
I have something for you are you ready
for guess what yes parkour competition
you bros will decide who wins yes that's
the point of parkour you just let your
body do the work and your mind not do
the thinking
go yes
Wow amazing parkour do something up what
she's gonna do
pole dancing Marzia let's see boots a
core master from 2015
that's pretty impressive
yeah working
I think you want
I want to do it
watch out for the hit who won leave a
comment down below my god Marzia I'm
bleeding
oh that's not cleaning now I'm bleeding
you're bleeding very hard I'm dying
the madness begins I didn't order a
pizza
it is almost 12:00
I just finished another day of shooting
got this pillow from from the people I
work with Kevin and Daymond and everyone
is so cool to work with on this thing
I'm gonna miss when this thing is over
but today was another awesome day and
I'm so tired just ready to go to sleep
so I'll end it here
it's always stay out how do you you
don't yo I serious just blew it
come here